[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic géodésique et relativité
quelle est la distance entre ces deux
points on peut se munir d'une règle
graduée et en la plaçant sur l'écran
lire le nombre de centimètres qui sépare
le point à du point b on pourrait
également demander à une fourmi de
marché tout droit de l'un à l'autre et
de compter le nombre de pas qu'elle doit
effectuer
on mesure alors la distance en cm dans
le premier cas et en nombre de pas dans
le deuxième mais imaginons maintenant
que les points a et b sont à la surface
d'une sphère
quelle est désormais la distance qui les
sépare à première vue il suffit de
prendre la règle graduée de la placer
entre le point a et le point b et de
mesurer le nombre de centimètres qui les
séparent mais si on demande à la fourmi
de marché du point a au point b
celle-ci se situant à la surface de la
sphère elle va parcourir un chemin
différent de la ligne droite formée par
la règle la fourmi a dû marcher
davantage car la sphère est courbé il
lui a fallu parcourir tout un arc de
cercle
elle ne mesure pas la même distance que
la règle graduée
en réalité la sphère est une surface à
deux dimensions que l'on a plongé dans
un espace à trois dimensions la distance
que mesure la règle est une distance
dans l'espace en trois dimensions en
effet on autorise la règle a quitté la
surface de la sphère
al'inverse la distance mesurée par la
fourmi est une distance en deux
dimensions qui épousent la géométrie à
la surface en mathématiques
si on s'intéresse à la sphère et à sa
géométrie intrinsèque
on ne va pas tant se concentrer sur la
longueur mesuré par la règle mais plutôt
sur la distance que doit parcourir la
fourmi
mais parle alors de metric une métrique
est un objet mathématique qu'on associe
à une surface en tout point de cette
surface la métrique va nous fournir une
grille qui épousent la géométrie de
notre objet de sour times eurent et des
longueurs et des angles par exemple pour
mesurer la longueur du chemin parcouru
par la fourmi on va additionner la
longueur de chacun de ses pas à chaque
pas la métrique nous fournit une grille
sur laquelle on va pouvoir mesurer la
petite distance que vient de parcourir
la fourmi en répétant l'opération pour
chacun de ses pas on obtient alors la
longueur totale de son trajet
se pose alors un problème qui est celui
de connaître la distance réelle entre a
et b à la surface de la sphère en effet
par définition la distance entre deux
points et la longueur du chemin le plus
court qui les relie or rien ne nous dit
que le chemin parcouru par la fourmi est
optimale peut-être que celle ci va se
déplacer en zigzag et emprunté un trajet
qui est trop long par rapport à la vraie
distance qui sépare ces deux points
la métrique nous permet de connaître la
longueur du trajet parcouru à la surface
de la sphère mais elle ne nous assure en
rien que ce trajet le plus court
possible trouver la vraie distance entre
a et b revient ainsi à trouver la
trajectoire la plus rapide qui puisse
les relier
pour ce faire on peut imaginer qu'on
envoie des dizaines voire des centaines
de fourmies
chaque fourmi va essayer un chemin
différent toutes les fourmis parts du
point à mais certaines vont arriver plus
rapidement au point b et d'autres vont
prendre plus de temps
grâce à la métrique on peut mesurer la
longueur de chacun de ces trajets et en
les comparant on peut ainsi trouver la
fourmi qui a parcouru le chemin le plus
court en imaginant qu'on puisse tester
absolument tous les trajets possibles ce
qui est mathématiquement faisable on est
maintenant capable de déterminer le
chemin le plus court
c'est le chemin optimal pour aller de ab
c'est ce chemin qui détermine réellement
la distance entre les deux points on
appelle ce type de chemins qui optimise
la durée d'un trajet une géodésique
c'est la généralisation d'une ligne
droite c'est à dire intuitivement une
trajectoire qui se parcourt quand on
avance un pied devant l'autre
quand on suit une géodésique chaque pas
nous fait avancer sur la surface dans la
même direction que le pas qui précède on
ne va jamais tourné à la surface d'un
plan les géodésique sont simplement les
lignes droites
c'est pour cette raison qu'on petit
mesurer des distances avec une règle
quand on cherche à relier deux points
passés par un troisième point qui
s'éloigne de la ligne droite va
forcément nécessiter un temps de trajet
plus long c'est ce qu'on appelle en
termes techniques
l'inégalité triangulaire à la surface
d'une sphère les géodésique sont les
grands cercles
c'est à dire les cercles qui parcourt la
plus grande circonférence possible sur
la terre par exemple les lignes de
longitude sondés géodésique un vol de
rome à copenhague deux villes qui se
trouvent à la même longitude sera le
plus court possible en suivant cette
courbe
par contre mis à part l'équateur les
lignes de latitude ne sont pas des
géodésique en effet elles ne sont pas
des grands cercles sur la sphère pour
relier deux points d'eux mêmes latitudes
comme par exemple paris et québec
il existe donc un chemin qui est plus
rapide pour aller plus loin le domaine
de la géométrie différentielle développe
toute une panoplie d'outils
mathématiques qui vont permettre de
caractériser la courbure d'une surface
l'un de ces objets les plus importants
est ce qu'on appelle le temps soeur de
courbure pour simplifier ce temps soeur
de courbure est une grandeur qui exprime
l'évolution des géodésique les unes par
rapport aux autres
ceux-ci caractérise la courbure d'une
géométrie car plus est les courbes et
plus léger au désir en surface vont se
rapprocher ou s'éloigner rapidement les
unes des autres et à linverse plus une
surface plane
- et les courbes et et moins c'est
géodésique vont avoir tendance à
s'éloigner entre elles elles vont plutôt
rester parallèle quand on s'intéresse à
des surfaces plus complexes les jo
désirent peuvent prendre des formes
étonnantes à la surface de cet entonnoir
par exemple les lignes droites semble
dévier au voisinage du trou central
drôle de coïncidence
lorsqu'on les regarde vue de dessus les
géodésique à la surface de l'entonnoir
semble se courber d'une façon similaire
ou rayons lumineux qui passe à proximité
d'un trou noir
et pour cause si la lumière est dévié
par un trou noir
c'est exactement pour la même raison
l'univers dans lequel nous vivons n'est
pas une surface à deux dimensions comme
un plan une sphère où un entonnoir
c'est une hyper surface à quatre
dimensions trois dimensions des espaces
et une dimension de temps on appelle
cette surface l'espace temps tous les
objets de l'univers évolué dans l'espace
temps de la même façon que la fourmi se
déplaçait sur la sphère mais dans
l'espace temps la distance entre deux
événements prend en compte non seulement
leur écart dans l'espace mais aussi leur
écart dans le temps d'après le principe
d'inertie
s'ils ne sont soumis à aucune force tous
les corps se déplace dans ligne droite
ainsi tous les objets de l'univers
lorsqu'ils ne sont ni accéléré ni dévié
par une force vont suivre les géodésique
c'est-à-dire les lignes droites dans la
géométrie de l'espace temps l'espace ton
qui composent notre univers est très
vaste et la métrique qui va décrire sa
géométrie prend différentes formes en
fonction de l'endroit où on se place
dans une région vide de l'univers
l'espace-temps est relativement plat les
géodésique sont alors rectiligne et tous
les objets ou rayons lumineux se déplace
dans ligne droite dans l'espace et à
vitesse constante dans le temps on parle
de métriques de minkowski
c'est le type d'espace-temps qui est
décrit par la relativité restreinte
ici tout mouvement entre deux objets est
relatif car l'espace temps et bla et
donc toutes les positions et toutes les
directions sont équivalentes
mais à proximité d'un corps massif comme
la terre où le soleil l'espace-temps se
courbent pour décor qui sont sphériques
isolé est relativement stable dans le
temps on parle alors d'une métriques de
schwarzschild c'est la métrique la plus
commune en relativité générale les
géodésique dans cette métrique
correspondent à des trajectoires dévier
ou à des orbites
par exemple si la lune tourne autour de
la terre
c'est parce qu'elles se déplacent en
ligne droite suivant une géodésique mais
à l'intérieur d'une géométrie courbet un
peu à la façon de l'entonnoir qu'on a vu
précédemment
la seule différence est que
contrairement à l'entonnoir
ici la géodésique n'est pas uniquement
une ligne dans l'espace elle décrit
aussi la trajectoire de l'objet dans le
temps à la surface de la terre
si une pomme tombe d'un arbre alors
qu'au départ elle est immobile c'est
parce que la courbure de l'espace-temps
engendrés par la terre des formes
légères des ics
entre temps et espace la pomme qui se
déplaçait uniquement dans le temps va
progressivement dévier son écoulement
dans le temps va se transformer
progressivement en vitesse dans l'espace
et la pomme va se mettre à tomber
lorsque l'objet attirant est extrêmement
massif comme un trou noir statique la
métrique de schwarzschild décrit une
sorte de trou une région sphérique de
l'espace tout autour de l'objet un peu
comme le trou d'un entonnoir au niveau
de cette sphère la métrique semble
rompue c'est ce qu'on appelle le rayon
de schwarzschild ou plus communément
l'horizon des événements du point de vue
d'un observateur externe au trou noir
aucun objet ne peut franchir cet horizon
cela dit ce n'est en fait qu'une
illusion
un peu comme le pôle nord à la surface
de la terre qui semble se rompre
lorsqu'on leur présente sur une carte
c'est ce qu'on appelle une singularité
apparente en réalité du point de vue
d'un vaisseau spatial qui se
rapprocherait du trou noir
il est tout à fait possible de franchir
cette zone mais malheureusement pour lui
en progressant à l'intérieur du trou
noir
il finirait quand même par se heurter à
une singularité réel au centre du trou
noir un point où la courbure de l'espace
temps devient un fini et que la science
moderne ne s'est pas encore d'écrire
pour finir il existe dans l'univers une
multitude d'autres endroits qui sont
munis de metric plus complexes comme par
exemple la métrique de care qui décrit
des trous noirs avec une rotation très
rapide sur eux mêmes leurs singularités
centrale a alors une étonnante forme
d'anneau ou encore la métrique flr w
pour friedman le maître robertson walker
qui décrit une approximation de l'espace
temps à grande échelle une sorte
d'univers dans son ensemble introduisant
une courbure et une expansion du cosmos
tout entier ce qui est à la base de la
théorie du big bang
[Musique]